first for the crunchy topping hey olive
oil in a frying pan add chopped garlic
[Music]
and breadcrumbs
[Music]
cook another medium heat until the
breadcrumbs of golden
season and drain on kitchen paper
[Music]
for the source add the oil from your
sardines to a hot pan fry finely dice
chili and chopped garlic next cook dry
spaghetti in boiling water then chopped
in sardines into chunks and add to the
chili and garlic 10 sardines are a
brilliantly versatile ingredients to
have in your cupboard packed with
protein full of super healthy omega-3
oils and delicious next drain your pasta
and combined with a sardine chilli and
garlic mixture add leaves of fresh
oregano and mix in handfuls of rocket
to serve par high and top with the
crispy garlic bread crumbs
ready in under 15 minutes spaghetti with
chili sardines and oregano healthy party
and full of flavor perfect pasta in
moments
the sausage meat sauce
finish with freshly grated Parmesan
spooning creme fraiche
and dot with lumps of creamy ricotta
cheese